también la tarde función del director
del estado civil
la madre de nicole murió tal como cinco
mil otros jubilados durante la primera
ola de la pandemia pero no es el virus
el que la mató
ocho días antes de su deceso el médico
me llamó para informarme que mi madre
estaba completamente deshidratada en
aquel momento el establecimiento estaba
rodeado por las autoridades la
centenaria quien estaba bien unas
semanas antes se encuentra librada a
ella misma hace falta personal
los que quedan están desbordados nicole
quien instaló una webcam para ver a su
madre a distancia
descubre imágenes preocupantes
tal como aquí donde hilda parece no
recibir suficiente ayuda para
alimentarse y llevar un vaso de agua a
su boca un vaso que la encargada le
lleva a lleno 20 minutos más tarde le
hice seguimiento con la cámara que tenía
en su habitación y yo a distancia veía
que sufría pero no ellas fue necesario
llamar al jefe de unidad el coordinador
para decirle mi madre sufre haga algo
desde su casa con su teléfono
nicole asiste impotente a los últimos
días de vida de su madre me permitieron
ir a verla
pasé el sábado anterior a su muerte y el
domingo 45 minutos con ella cuando uno
entraba olía a muerte
era lúgubre nicole como la mayoría de
las familias de víctimas no podrá
enterrarla permanecerá confinada con su
tristeza y esta pregunta porque esa
hecatombe en estos establecimientos
especializados para adultos mayores que
registraban al mismo tiempo hasta las
tres cuartas partes de la víctima de
coronavirus en quebec eran números creo
ya no eran personas el ch sld no estaba
preparado para esta crisis
no estaba listo para hacerle frente a la
crisis las mismas conclusiones aparecen
una y otra vez en los informes a lo
largo ya lo ancho de quebec y en otros
lugares en canadá nos dirigimos a
ontario donde un año después la pandemia
sigue haciendo estragos
la provincia está cerrada a la tercera
ola desplazó el epicentro de la crisis
de montreal a toronto donde para candás
reinick 20 años de cuidados para con
adultos mayores no se ha sacado ninguna
lección de la hecatombe de la primavera
2020 nuestros miembros están agotados
hay una crisis con los enfermos y han
recibido poca o ninguna ayuda entre la
primera y la segunda ola la situación
empeoró porque perdimos a mucha gente
mucha gente se fue del sector ya no
trabajan en el ámbito del cuidado a
largo plazo y el gobierno no hizo nada
ni para retenerlos ni para traer
personal entonces la crisis se agravó
una red que no da más aquí la segunda
ola mató más que la primera el peor
récord lo tiene el sector de estructuras
de cuidado privadas con fines de lucro
extendí quer uno de los gerentes más
importantes de este tipo de
establecimientos en la provincia se negó
a ser entrevistado para la investigadora
tamala daily es necesario hablar sobre
el método de negocio de estas empresas
las residencias públicas sin fines de
lucro reinyectan sus beneficios en sus
establecimientos mientras que las de
fines de lucro los retiran no aumentan
el personal al mismo ritmo que las
residencias públicas sin fines de lucro
esto lo reveló la pandemia a las
residencias que funcionaban así no
respetaban las normas les fue peor en
general en canadá tenemos tendencia a no
valorar a los adultos mayores
de regreso a quebec luz al final del
túnel la vacunación en curso permite la
reactivación de algunas actividades
sociales inimaginable hace algunos meses
tengo un pequeño perro que viene a
visitarme
aquí podemos salir a la terraza
sabes los pequeños placeres de la vida
son agradables
pero me gustaría salir más
ir a un restaurante de tomarme una copa
de vino con amigos
y aún en parte confinada a quebec tal
como el resto de canadá adelanta una
carrera para vacunarse por la
propagación de las variantes del
coronavirus por su lado el gobierno
provincial desbloqueo finalmente
recursos inesperados para socorrer a la
población una de las más envejecidas del
mundo
para 356 residentes aquí teníamos cuatro
jefes de unidad solamente que se
ocupaban de 90 residentes la misma
cantidad de empleados hoy en día tenemos
8 entonces se tomó conciencia y también
vemos lo que la vacuna le aporta a la
población hay un efecto nos da esperanza
el ministerio de salud de quebec promete
un plan de acción exhaustivo y el final
de los establecimientos privados no
autorizados en quebec en ontario la
comisión kobe 19 de investigación sobre
los cuidados de larga duración acaba de
publicar sus conclusiones con estas
palabras no había ningún plan para
proteger a los residentes